The joe rogan experience.
Is any of this all,
all,
all the pressure and the scandal every three weeks.
Is this a does,
is it weigh on you?
Is it,
is it difficult?
How are you feeling?
Like when,
when all this new thing,
yeah.
It's like,
it's like simultaneously the worst possible thing in the best possible thing
that could happen.
Well,
financially it's been a boom,
right?
Yes.
It's which has areas as a knee.
Oh,
well,
yes.
I mean,
the thing that I've,
I shouldn't say this,
but I'm going to because it's just so,
God damn funny.
I can't help but say that I figured out how to monetize social justice warriors
is what it is.
I know.
It's so funny.
It just can't believe it.
It's other way.
It just,
every time.
I think that while it's just one of the surreal circumstances that characterize
my life,
it's like I'm driving the social justice activists in Canada mad because if they
let me speak,
then I get to speak and then more people support me on patriot.
It's like,
hmm,
that's annoying.
It's like God damn capitalist.
He's make more money off this ideological warfare.
It's like,
okay fine,
let's go protest.
If they go protest me,
then that goes up on Youtube and then my patron account goes way up.
So it's like they don't know what to do.
And so one of the things that keep accusing me,
yeah,
they keep accusing me of uh,
like hauling in the loot.
And I think,
well look,
here's the situation guys.
I give away everything I do online for free.
It's free and people are giving me money.
They're just sending it to me.
I'm not twisting their arm.
I'm not even asking them for it.
Well I guess that's not exactly right cause I set up the Patriot account,
but that's more complicated than it looks that a lot of that was curiosity.
And I thought,
well,
I could increase the production quality of my online videos.
It was also the potential of you being removed from the universal there.
Yes.
Well that and that was real life.
Oh yeah.
Oh and yeah,
people wanted that.
Oh yeah.
They haven't stopped wanting that in October when the Lindsay Shepherd scandal
broke.
And it would look so bad for the left wing media logs,
like 200 University of Toronto community members signed a petition to get me
fired again.
And I was kind of upset about that and this is what my life has been like.
It's so,
my son came over that day and I said,
Jesus,
Julian,
you know,
I'd like 200 people at the faculty member at in at the University of Toronto,
petitioned the Faculty Association and then they sent in a petition to the
administration to get me fired.
It was the faculty association.
That's my union.
They didn't even contact me and Julian said,
ah,
don't worry about it,
dad.
It was only 200 people and I thought that's where my life is.
Like,
it's like a day where 200 people sign a petition to get me fired as a professor.
My son can come in and say,
well,
that's not so bad.
It's like it's only 200 pizza cheese scales.
God,
that's right.
It's so,
it's so surreal because you could say that online and look what's happening and
then the support would be overwhelming for who knows how many people do
you administrate times of that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Well,
in the administration at the University of Toronto,
like they didn't take,
they didn't take it seriously at all,
called helped me remove it.
Didn't cause it
any,
didn't even cause a ripple.
Now who are these 200 people and what was their motivation?
Oh,
well they're hard to say what their motivations are.
Not very happy.
The read the transcript or listen to those recordings.
Yup.
How could they possibly be against you based on that?
Oh,
because they think that the people who,
who,
who conducted the inquisition were right.
Well,
that's madness.
Oh yes.
But it look,
look,
I mean,
I mean there's formally like 20 members of Pim,
lots and Rambo counters faculty that was communications at Wilfrid.
Laurier wrote a letter supporting them.
So that's why it's not an isolated incident.
It's like,
no,
no.
They thought that what they were doing was right.
It's mass hysteria.
Yep.
While there is an element of that that's for sure.
And there's certainly a,
again,
I hate to bring this term up again,
but this toxic tribalism thing and it's like they are there supporting their own
and they understand that their own ideologies have been completely connected to
the same type of group think that's going against Lindsay Shepherd.
And that meeting when they tried to paint her as a radical right winger and does
her well,
she certainly isn't.
Of course not.
And neither of you,
I mean the whole thing is ridiculous and you're not outright,
you're not a neo Nazi.
You're not.
I've,
I've read a lot of crazy things about you and knowing you personally seeing this
stuff,
I'm like,
this is,
this is a fascinating
Tommy,
that's for sure.
That's for sure.
Yeah.
And it's been,
well,
it's been crazily,
I'm,
what would I say,
crazily stressful.
It's,
it's the best way to describe it is surreal.
Yeah.
Like I'm,
it's like I stepped outside myself.
I can't,
I can't put this in a box.
I don't know what to make of it.
I don't know what to make of the channel four interview.
You know?
It's like,
what the hell?
Really?
It's,
it's,
it's crazy.
But yeah,
it's,
it's this,
these conversations are so limited by what you were saying before that they're
trying to get this five minute sound bite in,
and that's what television has become.
Yeah.
It's a dying media.
It doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense to sandwich these commercials in every 15 minutes or
whatever they do.
None of it makes any sense.
It's an archaic way of communicating ideas.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that is part of it too,
is that like I happened to catch a technological wave.
Well,
like you did,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
they're,
they're television offers nothing over youtube.
Nothing you can do,
do offers everything to my TV.
Yeah.
Well,
exactly.
Yeah.
And then there's no space requirements on youtube,
so you don't have to do this,
twist the complex event into a short sound bite and entertain everyone.
Right.
And it turns out too,
that there's this huge audience online for actual content,
like just genuine conversation.
Yeah.